once again thank you very much both of
you for coming I guess I have a two-part
question for each of you for a second
you said that the European model of
secularization would not really be
exported to other parts of the world
what do you think of European
secularization itself where itself is
heading we see for the last five six
decades that cyclization definitely has
been on the rise do you think it will
continue to be on the rise until it
reaches high level I mean if you just
talk about for example the atheism which
is I think one manifestation if you like
of secularization we see that the
figures of people who don't really
believe in any type of divinity is
definitely on the rise in the last six
seven decades the question is where is
this heading do you think it will reach
a very high level in the high 90s or
will it taper out or will it backlash
and we see a resurgence even in Europe
as we see in other parts of the world
that's the first part of the question
second part is to our other speaker
where do you think turkey itself is
heading as straddling between its
Islamic site and its European side
suppose politics does not get involved
which is a very big if but suppose it
doesn't as a person from that area of
the world what are your gut instincts
where's all this heading because we've
read a lot this week about Turkey in
particular so I'm just curious to see
your inside perspective of the issue so
I mean I guess I guess I would say two
things about about the religious future
of Europe first thing is that within the
Protestant world at least those
religious movements and denominations
that are thriving are ones that exhibit
all or most of the organizational
features that I highlighted at the end
of my talk and so the second part of my
answer would be that to agree to which
religious resurgence in Europe occurs it
will depend a lot and whether or not
robust movements that have learned those
kinds of lessons arise within within
Europe
or not that I think is you know I mean
there are limits to the kinds of
prediction that big limits which social
science can aspire and I think that's
about as far as whether or not such
movements will arise from those I mean
it's difficult to know where turkey is
hidden really I think because I mean it
just as one sees a kind of perhaps what
could what one could characterize as
accommodation you know there's a
religious party or religious a part of
its religious origins or with some kind
of it was just identity in government
and things go as normal there have been
new crisis that have been brought about
you know by the actions of the
Constitutional Court or you know or by
kind of by these political crisis that
have been seen in the last year or so so
it's difficult to know um I mean I think
the choice for Turkey right now is that
between Islam and Europe definitely
because I mean that we see that many of
the the political party Justice and
Development Party for example although
it has now kind of stopped its it's kind
of active defense of reforms to join the
EU it is actually the most pro-eu party
that you know among the major parties so
the choice is not really between the two
and i would i would argue that the
Turkish secularism right now is not
aligned necessarily with European
political values I mean it tells in the
1920s when it was kind of first
instituted more strongly of course it's
as origins and in reforms under late
ottoman empire but when these radical
secularizing reforms were made some
aspects of it i would say or the way
that it institutionalized certain
political arrangements was very much in
line with with the kind of with europe
but now actually that that its rigidity
has has has put it into into a
confrontation with let's say in
political liberals in turkey so it
not necessarily I mean whether whether
the militants secularists will have the
upper hand or the you know more kind of
this religious party and its movement
will have the upper hand I don't think
that's certain but in either way I don't
think Europe lies necessarily on one
side of it or the European kind of
orientation lies in either side of that
conflict if anything I think in the
current situation at least i think the
militant secular is kind of let's let's
take the military involvement in Turkish
politics I mean this that has been
something that European Commission
reports on Turkey have again and again
criticized repeatedly that has always
been one of the major items that the
call for a reform in in pulling military
more out of the politics and and that
has been actually kind of you know the
secular is don't like that that much
they want to have it as a safeguard so
so I think if anything perhaps we can
say that kind of the more European
europeanization of turkey may
interestingly lie in kind of this
movement the militant secular is not
having the upper hand